[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara der weg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag die vom sport hat norbert
könig genormt und das sind unsere themen
heute
grünes licht für die ampel die spd
stimmt mit 98,8 prozent für eine
koalition mit den liberalen und den
grünen
rote karte für ungeimpfte in vielen
bundesländern dürfen in den meisten
geschäften ab heute nur noch geimpfte
und genesene einkaufen
und protest auf den straßen in hamburg
und anderswo demonstrieren tausende
gegen die verschärften corona regeln ein
fackelzug in sachsen löste empörung aus
als erste der drei ampel parteien hat
die spd auf einem sonderparteitag ja
gesagt zur neuen regierungskoalition
damit ist olaf scholz dem kanzleramt
wieder einen schritt näher dieser
machtwechsel sei ein ganz besonderer
aufbruch betonte scholz und das
dreierbündnis sollen nicht nur vier
jahre halten aus berlin britta
spiekermann und andreas ruppert
am ende ist für die spd alles in
trockenen tüchern
die sozialdemokratische partei
deutschlands hat dem koalitionsvertrag
mit mit bis 90 die grünen und der fdp
mit
98,8
ampelbündnis abgesegnet zuversichtlich
zeigt sich der der mittwoch zum kanzler
gewählt werden
und nun machen wir uns an die arbeit
zuvor hatte scholz das
regierungsprogramm skizziert er redet
frei spricht viel von bürgernähe respekt
und auf tour dies wird eine regierung
von drei parteien die mehr fortschritt
für deutschland wagen wollen darum geht
es doch zuvor habe etwas anderes
priorität dass wir die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger schützen dass wir
das land zusammenhalten dass wir die
korona pandemie bekämpfen mit aller
kraft die wir haben die spd hat nicht
all ihre forderungen durchgesetzt zwar
kommt ein höherer mindestlohn höhere
steuern für vermögende aber nicht das
sieht die parteilinke kritisch auch das
thema armutsbekämpfung komme zu kurz bei
einer inflationsrate von über fünf
prozent bei heizkosten erhöhungen
stromkosten erhöhungen lebensmittel sind
wahnsinnig teuer geworden kleidung etc
pp ist das einfach viel zu wenig für den
künftigen generalsekretär ist der
koalitionsvertrag nicht in stein
gemeißelt gerade deswegen gelte wo sich
die realität verändert zugreifen und
dinge vereinbaren und durchsetzen zu
können die noch nicht in einem
koalitionsvertrag angelegt bewegen sind
heute ging es um den koalitionsvertrag
doch wer wird was in der neuen regierung
und vor allem wer bekommt in diesen
zeiten das so wichtige
gesundheitsressort am montag wird die
spd darauf antworten geben
chacón talabani in berlin das ist ja
schon ein erstaunlich klares ergebnis ja
das kann man wohl sagen sieben
nein-stimmen und drei enthaltungen bei
rund 600 delegierten die abstimmen
dürften das heißt eigentlich 0
widerstand gegen einen koalitionsvertrag
in dem immerhin auch die spd natürlich
abstriche und zugeständnisse machen
musste es überwog offensichtlich bei
dieser abstimmung heute erst einmal die
begeisterung darüber dass mit olaf
scholz zum vierten mal in der deutschen
geschichte ein sozialdemokrat ins
kanzleramt einziehen wird wenn es wenn
alles gut geht nächste woche aber so
friedlich muss das ganze auch nicht
bleiben man hat auch zwischentöne gehört
zum beispiel bei den reden des
scheidenden parteivorsitzenden aber auch
dennoch parteivorsitzenden
saskia esken verzeihung und kevin
kühnert norbert walter borjans sagte
wörtlich die partei muss ideengeber
bleiben das heißt also sie wird druck
machen wenn sie das gefühl hat die
sozialdemokratische handschrift in der
ampel nicht deutlich genug ist das holz
wird sich in zukunft vielleicht nicht
nur mit fdp und grünen auseinandersetzen
müssen wenn es einmal ums kräftemessen
geht sondern auch mit den eigenen
genossinnen und genossen
dankeschön nach berlin konnte albert ii
die spd hat es vorgemacht jetzt zieht
die cdu nach ab heute können 400.000
parteimitglieder online oder per brief
vor entscheiden wer neuer parteichef
wird friedrich merz norbert röttgen oder
helge braun mit der dezember gibt es das
ergebnis wer dann tatsächlich nachfolger
von armin laschet wird das entscheidet
ein parteitag im januar
seit wochen mobilisieren gegner der
korona politik in sachsen radikalisiert
sich der protest gestern abend gab es
dort einen fackel aufmarsch vor dem
privathaus der gesundheitsministerin das
entsetzen ist parteiübergreifend groß
das erinnere an die dunkelsten kapitel
der deutschen geschichte sagte
bundesinnenminister seehofer der bild am
sonntag steffen moritz und axa conrad
es ist nur eine handvoll 20 30 menschen
aber ihr aufmarsch mit fackeln und
trommeln vor dem haus der sächsischen
gesundheitsministerin petra köpping ist
durchaus bedrohlich sie selbst haben ihn
ins netz gestellt abstoßend und
widerwärtig nennt die ministerin selbst
die zusammenrottung vor ihrem heim und
das sind keine proteste sondern
organisierte einschüchterungsversuche
von rechtsextremisten und verschwörungs
gläubigen die leider viel zu oft
vorkommen und sie fügt hinzu sie lasse
sich nicht einschüchtern
beistand bekommt sie nicht nur aus ihrer
partei
privat wohnen auszutreten das kannten
wir von der es im dritten reich das
brauchte eine eine knallharte antwort
des rechtsstaats das braucht ein
aufstand auch der der anständigen in
diesem land und das braucht einen
deutlichen widerspruch also das was da
passiert ist das darf nicht ohne
konsequenzen bleiben
der staatsschutz ermittelt und die
polizei erstattete anzeige wegen
verstößen gegen das versammlungsgesetz
und gegen die korona verordnung die gab
es heute auch massenhaft in hamburg wohl
mehr als 5000 gingen gegen die korona
maßnahmen auf die straße wenig abstand
wenig masken aber friedlich die
radikalisierung der bewegung ist nach
meinung von experten im westen weniger
stark als im osten deutschlands dass
solche leute in den letzten tagen und
wochen viel zu oft eben auch unbehelligt
durch sachsens städte ziehen konnten
auch das ist absolut nicht hinnehmbar
denn genau das hat diese leute zu
solchen dingen ermuntert es ist zu
erwarten dass es zu weiteren
gewalttätigen eskalationen kommt wie
gesagt egal ob mit oder ohne endlich
weil dieses milieu ist spezialisiert ist
ist nicht mehr erreichbar
es brauche jetzt klare kante denn nur
ein staat der seine regeln auch
durchsetze werde ernst genommen
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
64.500 zehn neuinfektionen innerhalb
eines tages das sind 2615 fälle weniger
als am samstag vor einer woche
378 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
dazu die sieben tage inzidenz steigt
leicht auf 4
142,7
wer an diesem adventssamstag geschenke
kaufen wollte der sah sich vielerorts
mit neuen chor ohne regeln konfrontiert
mehrere bundesländer haben heute schon
das eingeführt was bald deutschlandweit
gelten soll zweig in allen geschäften
des einzelhandels außerdem leben des
täglichen bedarfs wie das in hamburg ab
lief zeigt ralf zimmermann von seefahrt
gestern erst die neue verordnung
erlassen heute schon die 2g regeln
umgesetzt in hamburg zeigten sich vor
allem die großen einkaufspassagen
trotzdem gut vorbereitet im zertifikat
und ausweis werden gescannt und
kontrolliert dann gibt es ein blaues
bändchen für den ganzen tag jetzt können
wir nur hoffen dass es ein wellenbrecher
ist weil was sie alle wollen ist dass
wir alle gut durch diese pandemie
durchkommen mit möglichst wenigen toten
mit möglichst wenigen
krankenhausaufenthalten aber auch
natürlich mit möglichst vielen
geschäften wie auch danach noch wieder
richter machen können dem
weihnachtsgeschäft scheint die 2g
regelungen nicht zu schaden trotz des
vielfachen schlange stehen ich finde ich
ein bisschen sicherer damit findet auch
der aufwand der wie ich jetzt gemacht
wird vollkommen in ordnung ich schön
dass genau richtig ist kommt viel zu
spät aber ich bin sehr glücklich dass
das eingeführt wird es ist ein quasi
lockdown für die ungeimpften und ich
denke wer keinen guten grund hat sollte
sich auch impfen lassen buchhandel und
blumenläden aber etwa sind ausgenommen
von 2g werden behandelt wie supermärkte
und drogerien was nicht jeder versteht
jetzt wurde ich eben kontrolliert im
anderen laden geht's nicht hab ein
bisschen verwundert für den handel muss
sich erst zeigen ob zweig für alle
wirtschaftlich funktioniert wichtig für
uns ist jetzt dass wir die klarheit
haben und wissen was gilt und dass das
dann hoffentlich auch länger gilt als
zwei wochen damit es dann auch bei jedem
ankommt in der information für die
weihnachtseinkäufe jedenfalls dürften
die bedingungen jetzt erst einmal klar
sein wenn ja wenn die maßnahmen dann
auch wirklich wirkung zeigen
gehen wir direkt rein ins geschehen nach
mainz zu bobby serien auf den
weihnachtsmarkt vor dem dom dort die 2g
plus masken pflicht bobby wie gehen die
leute damit um
ja man muss sagen und das sowohl die
besucherinnen und besucher als auch die
schausteller sich sehr diszipliniert an
diese regeln halten wer hier auf den
weihnachtsmann sich auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt aufhalten möchte wer
essen und trinken möchte der muss erst
mal seinen geimpft oder genießen den
nachweis vorzeigen und bekommt dann ein
solches bändchen hier und dieses
bändchen wird an jeder gute kontrolliert
wir haben das mal beobachtet und das
läuft tatsächlich sehr reibungslos ab
ohne größere proteste eigentlich ohne
proteste auch wenn es jetzt hinter mir
und recht voll ist es sind weniger
besucherinnen und besucher als sonst die
stadt mainz schätzt dass seit der
eröffnung des weihnachtsmarktes am 25
november rund 40 prozent weniger
menschen hier hingekommen sind als in
den jahren vor der pandemie
dankeschön zum mainzer weihnachtsmarkt
bakterien war das
verschärfte maßnahmen nicht nur auf
weihnachtsmärkten ob in geschäften beim
training oder selbst auf privaten feiern
überall werden tests verlangt
entsprechend groß ist die nachfrage nur
ausgerechnet jetzt werden die
schnelltests immer knapper und teurer
warum erklärt julia schröter in dieser
apotheke in worms geben sich die kunden
praktisch die klinke in die hand viele
fragen nach corona schnelltests noch
sind welche da aber viele sind es nicht
wann es nachschub gibt ist unklar
die schnelltests bei uns und auch bei
den kollegen sind ziemlich ausverkauft
das heißt im moment können wir keine
neue ware nachbestellen über unsere
normalen großhändler der markt ist
einfach im moment sehr
ähnlich die lage in drogeriemärkten
schnelltest sind mangelware oft ganz
ausverkauft oder rationiert ich war in
mehreren läden und hab dann im letzten
laden doch noch welche gekriegt aber es
ist schwer 3g am arbeitsplatz und
oftmals zweig plus also tests auch für
geimpfte im freizeitbereich der bedarf
ist stark gestiegen und der grund für
die knappheit sagen sie beim zuständigen
verband dazu kommt dass 90 prozent der
schnelltests aus fernost kommen
es ist kein problem der
produktionskapazitäten die sind
reichlich vorhanden sondern die
transportwege von china nach deutschland
sind
komplex sie dauern vier bis sechs wochen
bis die test tatsächlich hier sind bis
sie dann in den einzelhandel zu den
apotheken zu den tests zentren gelangen
in dieser mainzer test stelle haben sie
noch keinen mangel doch auch hier macht
sich die knappheit bemerkbar
wir bekommen zu spüren unter anderem
dass die preise im vergleich von vor
vier wochen sich knapp verdoppelt haben
unsere einkaufspreise und dass der bezug
von test auch deutlich schwieriger
geworden ist noch ist es experten gehen
aber davon aus dass sich die lage in den
kommenden wochen entspannt
zur papst reise nach zypern ist papst
franziskus heute in griechenland auch in
athen kritisierte er den umgang mit
flüchtlingen und warnte vor einfachen
antworten des populismus er will sich
selbst ein bild der situation der
tausenden migranten auf lesbos machten
bereits gestern hatte der 84-jährige in
zypern wollte und sklaverei in
aufnahmezentren verurteilt
und dann noch eine traurige nachricht
der comedian mirco nontschew ist tot er
starb gestern im alter von 52 jahren
bekanntwurde nontschew in den 90ern
durch die rtl sendung samstag nacht
seine spezialität war besonders
gestenreiche humor den er mit allen nur
erdenklichen tönen auf die spitze trieb
zu sehen war zuletzt in der comedy serie
lost und laughing
jetzt bist du dran norbert zunächst mit
einer personalentscheidung für den
gesamten sport in deutschland der neue
präsident des deutschen olympischen
sportbunds heißt thomas weikert er setzt
sich bei der mitgliederversammlung in
weimar deutlich mit 361 zu 56 stimmen
gegen die ehemalige fechterin claudia
bokel durch der 60 jahre alte jurist aus
limburg steht vor keiner beneidenswerten
aufgabe weigert früherer weltpräsident
im tischtennis ein mann mit kontakten
zur basis muss einen krisengeschüttelten
verband zukunftsfähig machen die zukunft
von deutschland braucht sport aber auch
sport in deutschland
braucht eine zukunft
vorgänger alfons hörmann zuletzt
zunehmend umstritten er soll eine kultur
der angst geschürt und viele mitarbeiter
verprellt haben claudia bokel die fecht
präsidentin in weimar nicht persönlich
anwesend die einzige gegenkandidatin
konnte eine klare mehrheit für weigert
nicht verhindern ist ja dann auch ein
zeichen
dass wir versuchen in zukunft
die eine hat hier wieder herzustellen
nachdem viel
streit war nach all den querelen kann es
für den dsb eigentlich nur bergauf gehen
aus der traum vom endspiel für das
deutsche tennis davis cup team in madrid
die zweisatzniederlage von jan lennard
struff gegen russlands top spieler
daniel medwedew besiegelte das
vorentscheidende 0 2 die russen spielen
im finale morgen gegen pro aktie
trauriger bundesliga rekord für greuther
fürth der aufsteiger verliert zum
zwölften mal nacheinander und das
überaus deutlich
leverkusen besiegte nämlich den
tabellenletzten mit 721 und vier
treffern von patrick schick hoffenheim
gewinnt im leeren stadion gegen
frankfurt 3 zu 2 mainz 05 bezwingt den
vfl wolfsburg mit 3 zu 0 augsburg
verliert das zweite geisterspiel des
tages 2 zu 3 gegen bochum und ein
unentschieden bielefeld die arminia
gegen köln eins zu eins das absolute
topspiel am abend heißt borussia
dortmund gegen bayern münchen gestern
union gegen leipzig 22 12 spiele morgen
dortmund würde die bayern nachher mit
einem sieg überholen leverkusen dritter
hoffenheim im aufwind punktgleich mit
union wolfsburg zurück auf 8 bochum auf
dem sprung in die obere tabellenhälfte
leipzig mit abwärtstrend bielefeld
bleibt vorletzter greuther fürth schon
nach 14 spielen praktisch ohne hoffnung
das aktuelle sportstudio gibt es hier im
fernsehen nicht vor 23 uhr 30 in unserer
mediathek und bei sportstudio de aber
schon um 23 uhr mit der ausführlichen
zusammenfassung dortmund gegen bayern
und studiogast timo boll
daumen hoch schließlich francesco
friedrich heute im zweierbob mit
alexander schiller er feiert in
altenberg den fünften sieg im fünften
saisonrennen und skisprung weltmeister
karl geiger bringt das deutsche team mit
einem 125 meter sprung noch auf platz
zwei hinter österreich beim
mannschafts-weltcup in miesbach
ja das war es eine menge sport und wir
freuen uns alle auf timo boll nachher
so ganz besonders der zweite advent
bringt uns schnee regen und glätte hier
und da auch sonne die details hat gleich
katja hat das heute journal mit
christian sievers um viertel nach elf
nach der spendengala ein herz für kinder
mir ist gerade mein mikro unter gefallen
tut mir leid danke für ihr interesse wir
alle wünschen ihnen ein schönes
wochenende bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend sehr eindrucksvoll kringelt
sich hier ein neues tief über
großbritannien ein es bringt uns morgen
neuen schnee und neuen regen heute gab
es ja sogar gefährlichen glatteisregen
und auch jetzt am abend müssen uns auf
schnee und regen einstellen einem band
zwischen dem erzgebirge und dem emsland
dieses schnee und regen band zieht im
laufe der nacht weiter nordwärts und aus
dem regen wird mehr und mehr schnee bis
zum frühen morgen erreichen die
schneefelder auch die ostsee gefährlich
glatt kann es auf den straßen aber
eigentlich überall sein ob nun schnee
oder schneeregen fällt oder nicht denn
die temperaturen sinken auf plus 3 bis
minus 3 grad am boden wird es also
überall frostig morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 1 und 6 grad
und auch morgen vormittag kann es an der
küste noch etwas schneien dann zieht ein
tief von der nordsee weiter südwärts und
das bedeutet es gibt schnee und
schneeregen schauer im westen
deutschlands auch an den alpen wird es
schneien es gibt allerdings auch eine
region wo sie eine chance auf
sonnenschein haben nämlich hier zwischen
der lausitz und dem spessart aber auch
zwischen dem oberrhein und dem allgäu in
der neuen woche geht es winterlich
weiter und die temperaturgegensätze
verschärfen sich im nordosten wird es
kälter im westen milder einen schönen
zweiten advent